moi je voudrais vous poser une question
plus personnelle quand vous étiez
conservateur avec votre camarade
belmondo belmondo vous dirais que cela
n'engageait que lui disait que rien qu'à
votre apparition à tous les deux je
crois qu'il y avait aussi jean pierre
marielle enfin vous étiez un petit
groupe comme ça les filles se sauver en
poussant des cris d'épouvanté parce que
vous n'aviez pas le physique type du
séducteur de l'époque
or maintenant ça marche très bien pour
vous est ce que ça marche bien bon oui
oui mais c'est oui comme vous avez
entendu parler de ça mais c'est vrai ça
souvenirs extrêmement douloureux nous
avons eu une adolescence contrarié parce
que dans les couloirs du conservatoire
nous provoquions l'angoissé la terreur
des femmes je ne sais pas pourquoi
peut-être que nos nos têtes ne
correspondait pas aux canons de l'époque
et nous avons été extrêmement frustré
affectivement et sexuellement aussi il
faut bien le dire
et heureusement la traquent y est non ma
carrière puis peut-être les modes
changent en tout ça c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu arrangé surtout en ce
qui concerne belmondo d'ailleurs non je
crois que sur ce plan aussi bien parce
que le temps passe très vite mais
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on parle de
théâtre aussi vous avez on voit plus
assez souvent tes intentions
merveilleuse époque où vous jouiez les
auteurs anglais pintor entre autres et
c'était de grands moments de théâtre
jacques l'agréable je vous remercie mais
si on se couche tellement tard j'ai
préféré oui mais ça je ne le fait la
forme d'abord
[Musique]